The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: And this is a
question based on where we
left off on Wednesday -- we were
talking about Coulomb's
force law to describe the
interaction between two
particles, and good job, most
of you got this correct.
So, what we're looking at here
is the force when we have two
charged particles, one positive,
one negative --
here, the nucleus
and an electron.
So, I know this is a simple
example and I can see everyone
pretty much got it right, and
probably those that didn't
actually made some sort of
clicker error is my guess.
But I wanted to use this to
point out that in this class
in general, any time you see
an equation to explain a
certain phenomenon, such as here
looking at force, it's a
good idea to check yourself by
first plugging it into the
actual equation, so you can
plug in infinity and this
equation here, and what you
would see is, of course, the
force, if you just solve the
math problem goes to zero.
But you can also look at it
qualitatively, so, if you
think about the force between
the electron and the proton,
you could just qualitatively
think about what's happening.
If they're close together
there's a certain force --
they're attracted because they
have opposite charges, but as
that gets further and further
away, that force is going to
get smaller and smaller, and
eventually the force is going
to approach zero.
So, it's a good kind of mental
check as we go through this
course to remember every time
there's an equation, usually
there's a very good reason for
that equation, and you can go
ahead and just use your
qualitative knowledge, you
don't have to just always stick
with the math to check
and justify your answers.
So, we can get started with
today's lecture notes.
And, as I mentioned, we left
off and as we started back
here to describe the atom and
how the atom holds together
the nucleus and the electron
using classical mechanics.
And today we'll finish that
discussion, and, of course,
point out actually the failure
of classical mechanics to
appropriately describe what's
going on in an atom.
So, then we'll get to turn to
a new kind of mechanics or
quantum mechanics, which will
in fact be able to describe
what's happening on this very,
very small size scale -- so on
the atomic size scale on the
order of nanometers or
angstroms, very small
particles.
And the reason that quantum
mechanics is going to work
where classical mechanics
fails is that classical
mechanics did not take into
account the fact that matter
has both wave-like and
particle-like properties, and
light has both wave-like and
particle-like properties.
So, we'll take a little bit of a
step back after we introduce
quantum mechanics, and talk
about light as a wave, and the
characteristic of waves, and
then light as a particle.
And one example of this is in
the photoelectric effect.
So, we just talked about the
force law to describe the
interaction between a proton
and an electron.
You told me that when the
distance went to infinity, the
force went to zero.
What happens instead when the
distance goes to zero?
What happens to the force?
Yeah.
So, the force actually goes to
infinity, and specifically it
goes to negative infinity.
Infinity is the force when we're
thinking about it and
our brains, negative infinity
is when we actually plug it
into the equation here, and the
reason is the convention
that the negative sign is just
telling us the direction that
the force is coming together
instead of pushing apart.
So, we can use Coulomb's force
law to think about the force
between these two particles --
and it does that, it tells us
the force is a function
of that distance.
But what it does not tell us,
which if we're trying to
describe an atom we really want
to know, is what happens
to the distance as
time passes?
So, r is a function of time.
But luckily for us, there's a
classical equation of motion
that will, in fact, describe how
the electron and nucleus
change position or change
their radius as
a function of time.
So, that's -- does anyone know
which classical law of motion
that would be?
Yup, so it's going to be
Newton's second law, force
equals mass times acceleration
-- those of you that are quick
page-turners, have a little
one-up on answering that.
And that tells us force as a
function of acceleration, we
want to know it though as a
function of radius, so we can
just take the first derivative
and get ourselves to velocity.
So, force is equal to
mass times dv /dt.
But, of course, we want to go
all the way to distance, so we
take the second derivative and
we have this equation for
force here.
And what we can do in order
to bring the two equations
together, is to plug in the
Coulomb force law right here.
So, now we have our Coulomb
force law all plugged in here,
and we have this differential
equation that we could solve,
if we wanted to figure out
what the force was at
different times t, or at
different positions of r.
So, all you will have the
opportunity to solve
differential equations in
your math courses here.
We won't do it in this
chemistry course.
In later chemistry courses,
you'll also get to solve
differential equations.
But instead in this chemistry
course, I will just tell you
the solutions to differential
equations.
And what we can do is we can
start with some initial value
of r, and here I write r being
ten angstroms. That's a good
approximation when we're talking
about atoms, because
that's about the size
of and atom.
So, let's say we start off
at the distance being ten
angstroms. We can plug that
into this differential
equation that we'll have and
solve it, and what we find out
is that r actually goes to zero
at a time that's equal to
10 to the negative 10 seconds.
So, let's think qualitatively
for a second about what that
means or what the real
meaning of that is.
What that is telling us is that
according to Newtonian
mechanics and Coulomb's force
law, is that the electron
should actually plummet into
the nucleus in 0.1
nanoseconds.
So, we have a little bit
of a problem here.
And the problem that we have
is that what we're figuring
out mathematically is not
exactly matching up with what
we're observing experimentally.
And, in fact, it's often kind of
difficult to experimentally
test your mathematical
predictions -- a lot of people
spend many, many years testing
one single mathematical
prediction.
But, I think all of us right
now can probably test this
prediction right here, and we're
observing that, in fact,
all of us and all the atoms we
can see are not immediately
collapsing in less than
a nanosecond.
So, just, if you can take what
I'm saying for a moment right
now that in fact this should
collapse in this very small
time frame, we have to see that
there's a problem with
one of these two things, either
the Coulomb force law
or Newtonian mechanics.
So, what do you guys think is
probably the issue here?
So, it's Newtonian mechanics,
and the reason for this is
because Newtonian mechanics does
not work on this very,
very small size scale.
As we said, Newtonian mechanics
does work in most
cases, it does work when we're
discussing things that we can
see, it does work even
on things that are
too small to measure.
But once we got to the atomic
size scale, what happens is we
need to be taking into account
the fact that matter has these
wave-like properties, and we'll
learn more about that
later, but essentially classical
mechanics does not
take that into account at all.
So, we need a new kind of
mechanics, which is quantum
mechanics, which will accurately
explain the
behavior of molecules
on this small scale.
So, as I mentioned, the real
key to quantum mechanics is
that it's treating matter not
just like it's a particle,
which is what we were just
doing, but also like it's a
wave, and it treats light
that way, too.
The second important point to
quantum mechanics is that it
actually considers the fact that
light consists of these
discrete packets or
particle-like pieces of
energy, which are
called photons.
And if you think about what's
actually happening here, this
second point that light
consists of photons is
actually the same thing as
saying that light shows
particle-like properties, but
that's such an important point
that I put it separately, and
we'll cover that separately as
we go along.
So, we now have this new way
of thinking about how a
nucleus and an electron can
hang together, and this is
quantum mechanics, and we can
use this to come up with a new
way to describe our atom and the
behavior of atoms. But the
problem is before we do this,
it makes sense to take a
little bit of a step back and
actually make sure we're all
on the same page and
understanding why quantum
mechanics is so important and
how it works, and specifically
understanding what we mean when
we say that light is both
a particle and a wave, and that
matter is both a particle
and a wave. So, we'll move on to
this discussion of light as
a wave, and we really won't
pick up into going back to
applying quantum mechanics to
the atom until Friday, but in
the meantime, we'll really get
to understand the wave
particle duality of light
and of matter.
So, we'll start with thinking
about some properties of waves
that are going to be applicable
to all waves that
we're talking about, including
light waves.
The easiest kind of waves for us
to picture are ocean waves
or water waves, because we can,
in fact, see them, but
they have similar properties
to all waves.
And those properties include
that you have this periodic
variation of some property.
So, when we're talking about
water waves, the property
we're discussing is just
the water level.
So, for example, we have this
average level, and then it can
go high where we have the peak,
or it can go very low.
We can also discuss sound waves,
so again it's just the
periodic variation of some
property -- in this case we're
talking about density, so we
have high density areas and
low density areas.
So, regardless of the type of
wave that we're talking about,
there's some common definitions
that we want to
make sure that we're all
able to use, and
the first is amplitude.
And when we're talking about
the amplitude of the wave,
we're talking about
the deviation from
that average level.
So, if we define the average
level as zero, you can have
either a positive amplitude
or a negative amplitude.
So, sometimes people get
confused when they're solving
problems and call the amplitude
this distance all
the way from the max to the
min, but it's only half of
that because we're only going
back to the average level.
So, what we really want to
talk about here is light
waves, and light waves have the
same properties as these
other kind of waves in that
they're the periodic variation
of some property.
So, when we're discussing
light waves, what we're
talking about is actually
light or electromagnetic
radiation, is what we'll
be calling it
throughout the course.
And that's the periodic
variation
of an electric field.
So, instead of having the
periodic variation of water,
or the periodic variation of
air density, here we're
talking about an
electric field.
We know what an electric field
is, it's just a space through
which a Coulomb force
operates.
And the important thing to
think about when you're
talking about the fact that it's
a periodic variation, is
if you put a charged particle
somewhere into an electric
field, it will, of course, go in
a certain direction toward
the charge it's attracted to.
But you need to think about the
difference, if you have a
particle here on your wave, it
will go in one direction.
But remember, waves don't just
have magnitude, they also do
have direction.
So, if instead you put your
particle somewhere down here
on the electric field, or on the
wave, the electric field
will now be in the other
direction, so your particle
will be pushed the other way.
And from physics you know that,
of course, if we have a
propagating electric field, we
also have a perpendicular
magnetic field that's going
back and forth.
But in terms of worrying about
using the concepts of a wave
to solve chemistry problems in
this course, we can actually
put aside the fact, and only
focus on the electric field
part of things, because that's
what's going to be interacting
with our charged particles,
such as our electrons.
So, other properties of waves
that you probably are all
familiar with but I just want
to review is the idea of a
wavelength.
If we're talking about the
wavelength of a wave, we're
just talking about the distance
that there is between
successive maxima, or of course,
we can also be talking
about the distance between
successive minima.
Basically, we can take any point
on the wave, and it's
the distance to that same point
later on in the wave.
So, that's what we call
one wavelength.
We also commonly discuss the
frequency of a wave, and the
frequency is just the number of
cycles that that wave goes
through per unit time.
So, by a cycle we'd basically
mean how many times we cycle
through a complete wavelength.
So, if something cycles through
five wavelengths in a
single second, we would just say
that the frequency of that
wave is five per second.
We can also mathematically
describe what's going on here
other than just graphing it.
So, if we want to look at the
mathematical equation of a
wave, we want to describe --
again as I mention, what we're
describing is the electric
field, we're not worrying
about the magnetic field here,
as a function of x and t
that's equal to a cosine [
2 pi x over wavelength,
minus 2 pi nu t ].
And note this is the
Greek letter nu.
This is not a v. Where we have
E, which is equal to the
electric field, what is x?
STUDENT: Position.
PROFESSOR: Yup, the position of
the wave. And what about t?
Yeah, so we're talking about
both position and time.
So what we can do if we're
talking about a wave is think
of it both in terms of position
time, but if we're
trying to visualize this -- for
example if we're actually
to graph this out, the easiest
thing to do is keep one of
these two variables constant,
either the x or the t, and
then just consider the
other variable.
So, for example, if we're to
hold the time constant, this
makes it a lot simpler of an
equation, because what we can
end up doing is actually
crossing out
this whole term here.
So what we're left with is just
that the electric field
as a function of distance is a
times cosine of the argument
there, which is now just
2 pi x over wavelength.
So, what we want to be able to
do, either when we're looking
at the graph or looking at the
equation up there, is to think
about different properties of
the wave. For example, to
think about at what point do we
have the wave where it's at
its maximum amplitude?
So, if we think about that, we
need to have a point where
we're making this argument of
the cosine such that the
cosine is going to all be equal
to one, so all we're
left with is that a term.
So, we can do that basically
any time that we have an
integer variable that is either
zero or an integer
variable of the wavelength.
So, for example, negative
wavelength or positive
wavelength are two times the
wavelength, because that lets
us cross out the term with the
wavelength here, and we're
left with some integer
multiple of just pi.
So, that's sort of the
mathematically how we get to
a, but we can also just look
at the graph here, because
every time we go one wavelength,
we can see that
we're back in a maximum.
So, I mentioned we should be
able to figure out where the
maximum amplitude is.
You should also just looking at
an equation, immediately be
able to figure out what that
maximum amplitude is in terms
of the height of it just by
looking at that a-term, here
we should also be able to know
the intensity of any light
wave, because intensity is just
the amplitude squared.
So, we should immediately be
able to know how bright or how
intense a light is just looking
at the wave equation,
or just by looking at a graph.
We can also do a similar
thing, and I'll keep my
distance from the board, but
we can instead be holding x
constant, for example, putting
x to be equal to zero, and
then all we're doing is
considering the electric field
as a function of t.
So, in this case we're crossing
out the first term
there, and we're left with
amplitude times the cosine of
2 pi nu times t.
And, of course, we can do the
same thing again, we can think
about when the amplitude is
going to be at its maximum,
and it's going to be any time
cosine of this term now is
equal to one.
So that will be at, for example,
negative 1 over nu,
or 0, or 1 over nu.
And again, we can just look at
our graph to figure that out,
that's exactly where
we're at a maximum.
So, 1 over nu is another term
we use and we call it the
period of a wave, and the period
is just the inverse of
the frequency.
And if we think about frequency,
that's number of
cycles per unit time.
So, for example, number of
cycles per second, whereas the
period is how much time it takes
for one cycle to occur.
And when we talk about units of
frequency, in almost every
case, you'll be talking about
number of cycles per second.
So, you can just write
inverse second, the
cycle part is assumed.
But you'll also frequently see
it called Hertz, so, Hz here.
So, if you're talking about five
cycles per second, you
can write five per second, or
you can write five Hertz.
The one thing you want to keep
in mind though is that Hertz
does not actually mean
inverse seconds, it
means cycles per second.
So, if you're talking about a
car going so many meters per
second, you can't say it's going
meter Hertz, you have to
say meters per second.
So, this really just means
for frequency,
it's a frequency label.
Alright.
So, since we have these terms
defined, we know the frequency
and the wavelength, it turns
out we can also think about
the speed of the wave, and
specifically of a light wave,
and speed and is just equal to
the distance that's traveled
divided by the time
the elapsed.
And because we've defined these
terms, we have ways to
describe these things.
So, we can describe the distance
that's traveled, it's
just a wavelength here.
And we can think about how
long it takes for a wave,
because waves are, we know not
just changing in position, but
the whole wave is moving forward
with time, we can
think about how long it takes
for wave to go one wavelength.
So, one distance that's
equal to lambda.
So, how much time would that
take, does anyone know?
So, would it take, for example,
the same amount of
time as the frequency?
The period, that's right.
So, it's going to take one
period to move that long.
And another way we can say
period is just 1 over nu or 1
over the frequency So, now
we know both the distance
traveled and the time
the elapsed.
So, we can just plug it in.
Speed is equal to the distance
traveled, which is lambda over
the time elapsed, which is 1
over nu. so, we can re-write
that as speed is equal to lambda
times nu, and it turns
out typically this is reported
in meters per second or
nanometers per second.
So, now we have an equation
where we know the relationship
between speed and wavelength
and frequency, and it turns
out that we could take any wave,
and as long as we know
the frequency and the
wavelength, we'll be able to
figure out the speed.
But, of course, there's
something very special about
electromagnetic waves,
electromagnetic
radiation and the speed.
And it's not really surprising
for me to tell you that
electromagnetic radiation has
a constant speed, and that
speed is what we call the speed
of light, and typically
we abbreviate that as c, and
that's from the Latin term
celeritas, which means
speed in Latin.
That's one of four or five Latin
words I remember from
four years of high school Latin,
but it comes in handy
to remember speed of light.
And some of you may have
memorized what the speed of
light is in high school -- it's
about 3 times 10 to the 8
meters per second.
This is another example of
a constant that you will
accidentally memorize in this
course as you use it over and
over again.
But again, that we will supply
for you on the exam just in
case you forget it
at that moment.
And this is a very fast speed,
of course, it's about 700
million miles per hour.
So, one way to put that in
perspective is to think about
how long it takes for a
light beam to get from
earth to the moon.
Does anyone have any guesses?
Eight seconds, that
sounds good.
Anyone else?
These are all really good
guesses, so it actually takes
1.2 seconds for light
to travel from the
earth to the moon.
So, we're talking pretty
fast, so that's nice to
appreciate in itself.
But other than that point, we
can also think about the fact
that frequency and wavelength
are related in a way that now
since we know the speed of
light, if we know one we can
tell the other.
So, you can go ahead and switch
us to our clicker
question here.
So, we should be able to look
at different types of waves
and be able to figure out
something about both their
frequency and their wavelength,
and know the
relationship between the two.
So, it's up on this screen
here now, so we'll work
on the other one.
If you can identify which of
these statements is correct
based on what you know about
the relationship between
frequency and wavelength
and also just
looking at the waves.
Alright.
So, let's give ten more
seconds on that.
So, ten seconds on that.
Alright.
So, good job.
So, most people could recognize
that light wave a
has the shorter wavelength.
We can see that just by looking
at the graph itself --
we can see, certainly, this is
shorter from maxima to maxima.
This we can't even see
the next maxima,
so it's much longer.
And then, we also know that
means that it has the higher
frequency, because our
relationship between
wavelength and frequency
are inversely related.
And also, we know the
speed of light.
So, if we think about if it's a
shorter wavelength, we'll be
able to get a lot more
wavelengths in, in a given
time, than we would for
a longer wavelength.
So, we can switch back to the
notes and think about what
this means, and what this means
when we're talking about
all the different kinds of light
waves we have, and I've
shown a bunch here, is that if
we have the wavelength, we
also know the frequency
of these wavelengths.
So, for example, radio waves,
which have very long
wavelengths have very
low frequencies.
Whereas where we go to waves
that have very short
wavelengths, such a x-rays or
cosmic rays, they, in turn,
have very high frequencies.
So, it's important to get a
little bit of a sense of what
all these different kinds
of lights do.
You're absolutely not
responsible to memorize what
the wavelengths of the different
types of lights are,
but you do want to be
able to know the
general order of them.
So, if someone tells you they're
using UV light versus
x-ray light, you know that the
x-ray light is, in fact, at a
higher frequency.
So that's the important
take-away
message from this slide.
If we think about these
different types of lights,
microwave light, if it's
absorbed by a molecule, is a
sufficient amount of frequency
and energy to get those
molecules to rotate.
That, of course, generates
heat, so that's how your
microwaves work.
If we talk about infrared light,
which is at a higher
frequency here and a shorter
wavelength, infrared light
when it's absorbed by molecules
actually is enough
to cause molecules
now to vibrate.
If we move up to the more
high-frequency and divisible
light and all the way into UV
light, if you shine UV light
at certain molecules, it's going
to have enough energy to
actually pop those electrons
in that molecule up to a
higher energy level, which will
make more sense once we
talk about energy levels in
atoms, but that's what UV
light can do.
And actually, that's responsible
for fluorescence
and phosphorescence that
you see where typically
UV light comes in.
So, if you use a black lamp or
something and you excite
something up to a higher energy
level and then it
relaxes back down to its lower
energy state, it's going to
emit a new wavelength of light,
which is going to be
visible to you.
X-rays are at even a higher
frequency, and those are
sufficient to actually be
absorbed by a molecule and pop
an electron all the way
out of that molecule.
You can see how that would be
damaging to the integrity of
that molecule, that's why x-rays
are so damaging -- you
don't want to have electrons
disappearing for no good
reason from your molecules that
can cause the kind of
mutations we don't want to
be seeing in ourselves.
And then also as we go
higher, we have gamma
rays and cosmic rays.
Within the visible range of what
we can see, you also want
to know this relative order
that's pretty easy -- most of
us have memorized that
in kindergarten, so
that should be fine.
Just remembering that violet is
the end that actually has
the shortest wavelength, which
means that it also has, of
course, the highest frequency.
So, just an interesting fact
about this set of light, which
we're most familiar with, if we
think about our vision, it
turns out that our vision's
actually logarithmic and it's
centered around this
green frequency.
So, if instead of a red laser
pointer here, I had a green
one, you'd actually, to our
eyes, it would seem like the
green one was brighter, even if
the intensity was the same,
and that's just because our
eyes are centered and
logarithmic around this
green frequency set.
So, using the relationship
between frequency and
wavelength, we can actually
understand a lot about what's
going on, and pretty soon
we'll also draw the
relationship very soon to
energy, so it will be even
more informative then.
But I just want to point out one
of the many, many groups
at MIT that works with different
fluorescing types of
molecules, and this is Professor
Bawendi's laboratory
at MIT, and he works
with quantum dots.
And quantum dots are these just
very tiny, tiny crystals
of semiconductor material.
They're on the order of one to
ten nanometers, and these can
be shined on with UV light --
they have a lot of different
interesting properties, but one
I'll mention is that if
you excite them with UV light,
they will have some of the
electrons move to a higher
energy state, and when they
drop back down, they actually
emit light with a wavelength
that corresponds with the size
of the actual quantum dot.
So, from what we know so far,
we should be able to look at
any of these quantum dots,
which are depicted as a
cartoon here, but here we have
an actual picture of the
quantum dots suspended in some
sort of solution and shone on
with UV light, and you can see
that you can achieve this
whole beautiful range of colors
just by modulating the
size of the different dots.
And we should be able to know if
we're looking at a red dot
-- is a red dot, it's going to
have a longer wavelength, so
is this a higher or
lower frequency?
Yeah, and similarly, if someone
tells us that their
dot is blue-shifted, that should
automatically in our
heads tell us, oh it shifted
to a higher frequency.
And these dots are really
interesting in that you can,
I'm sure by looking at this
picture, already imagine just
a whole slew of different
biological or sensing
applications that you
could think of.
For example, if you were trying
to study different
protein interactions, you could
think about labeling
them with different colored
dots, or there's also a bunch
of different fluorescent
techniques that you could
apply using these dots, or you
could think of in-vivo
sensing, how useful these could
be if you could think of
a way to get them into your body
without being too toxic,
for example.
These are all things that the
Bawendi group is working on.
What they are real experts in is
synthesizing many different
kinds of these dots, and they
have a synthetic scheme that's
used by research groups
around the world.
The Bawendi group also
collaborates with people, both
at different schools
and at MIT.
One example, on some of their
biochemistry applications is
with another Professor at MIT,
Alice Ting and her lab.
So really what I want to point
out here is as we get more
into describing quantum
mechanics, these quantum dots
are one really good example
where a lot of the properties
of quantum mechanics
apply directly.
So, if you're interested, I put
the Bawendi lab research
website onto your notes.
And also, Professor Bawendi
recently did an interview with
"The Tech." Did anyone see that
interview in the paper?
So, three or four -- a few of
you read the paper last week.
So, you can either pick up an
old issue or I put the link on
the website, too.
And that's not just about his
research, it's also about some
of his memories as a student
and advice to all of you.
So, it's interesting to read and
get to know some of these
Professors at MIT a
little bit better.
So, one property that was
important we talked about with
waves is the relationship
between frequency and
wavelength.
Another very important property
of waves that's true
of all waves, is that you can
have superposition or
interference between
two waves.
So, if we're looking at waves
and they're in-phase, and when
I talk about in-phase, what I
mean is that they're lined up,
so that the maxima are in the
same position and the minima
are in the same position, what
we can have a something called
constructive interference.
And all we mean by constructive
interference is
that literally those two waves
add together, such as the
maxima are now twice as high,
and the minima are
now twice as low.
So, you can also imagine a
situation where instead of
being perfectly lined up, now we
have the minima being lined
up with the maxima here.
So, if we switch over to a
clicker question maybe on this
screen -- okay, can it be
done up there to switch?
So, we're still settling
in with the renovations
here in this room.
So, why don't you all go ahead
and tell me what happens if
you combine these two waves,
which are now out of phase?
So, let's -- okay, so, why
don't you all think about
would happen -- we'll start
with the thought exercise.
You can switch back to my
lecture notes then if this
isn't going.
Alright.
So, hopefully what everyone came
up with is the straight
line, is that what
you answered?
STUDENT: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: OK, very good.
And I didn't make you try
to draw the added, the
superimposed positive
construction in your notes,
but I think everyone can handle
drawing a straight line.
So, you can go ahead and draw
what happens when we have
destructive interference.
And destructive interference, of
course, is the extreme, but
you can picture also a case
where you have waves that are
not quite lined up, but they're
also not completely
out of phase.
So in that case, you're either
going to have the wave get a
little bigger, but not
twice as big or
a little bit smaller.
So, I think the easiest way to
think about interference is
not actually with light, but
sometimes it's easiest to
think about with sound,
especially when you're dealing
with times where you have
destructive interference.
Has anyone here ever been in a
concert hall where they feel
like they're kind of in a dead
spot, or you don't quite hear
as well, and if you move down
just two seats all of a sudden
it's just blasting at you --
hopefully not in this room.
But have people experienced
that before?
Yeah, I definitely experienced
it, too.
And really, all you're
experiencing there is
destructive interference
in a very bad way.
Halls, they try to design halls
such that that doesn't
happen, and I show an example of
a concert hall here -- this
is Symphony Hall in Boston,
and I can pretty much
guarantee you if you do go to
this Symphony Hall, you will
not experience a bad seat
or a dead seat.
This is described as actually
one of the top two or three
acoustic concert halls
in the whole world.
So, it's very well designed such
that they've minimized
any of these destructive
interference dead sounds.
So, it's nice, on a student
budget you can go and get the
worst seat in the house and you
can hear just as well as
they can hear up front, even
if you can't actually see
what's going on.
So, another example of
destructive interference is
just with the Bose headphones.
I've never actually tried these
on, but you see people
with them, and what happens here
is it's supposed to be
those noise cancellation
headphones.
All they do is they take in
the ambient noise that's
around it, and there's actually
battery in the
headphones, that then produces
waves that are going to
destructively interfere with
that ambient noise.
And that's how it actually gets
to be so quiet when you
have on, supposedly, these quite
expensive headphones.
So, that's light as a wave, and
the reason -- well, that
was sound as a wave, but light
as a wave is the same idea.
And it was really established
by the early 1900s that, in
fact, light behaved as a wave.
And the reason that it was so
certain that light was a wave
was because we could observe
these things -- we could see,
for example, that light
defracted, and we could see that
light constructively or
destructively could interfere
with other light waves, and
this was all confirmed
and visualized.
But also, around the time that
Thomson was discovering the
electron, there were some other
observations that were
going on, and the most
disturbing to kind of the
understanding of the universe
was the fact that there were
some observations about light
that didn't make sense with
this idea that light
is a particle.
And the photoelectric effect
is maybe the most clear
example of this.
So, the photoelectric effect is
the effect that if you have
some metal, and you can pick
essentially any metal you
want, and you shine light of a
certain frequency onto that
metal, you can actually pop off
an electron, and you can
go ahead and measure what the
kinetic energy of that
electron that comes off is,
because we can measure the
velocity and we know that
kinetic energy equals 1/2 m b
squared, and thanks to
Thomson we also know
the mass of an electron.
So, this is an interesting
observation, and in itself not
too disturbing, yet but the
important thing to point out
is that there's this threshold
frequency that is of the
metal, and each metal has a
different threshold frequency,
such as if you shine light on
the metal where the frequency
of the light is less than the
threshold frequency, nothing
will happen -- no electron will
pop off of that metal.
However, if you shine a light
with a frequency that's
greater than the threshold
frequency, you will be able to
pop off an electron.
So, people were making this
observation, but this wasn't
making any sense at all because
there was nothing in
classical physics that
described any sort of
relationship between the
frequency of light and the
energy, much less the energy of
an electron that would get
popped off of a metal that would
basically come off only
when we're hitting this
threshold frequency.
So, what they could do was
actually graph what was
happening here, so we can also
graph what was happening, and
what they found was that if we
were at any point below the
threshold frequency and we were
counting the numbers of
electrons that were popping off
of our metal, we weren't
seeing anything at all.
But if you go up the threshold
frequency, suddenly you see
that there's some number of
electrons that comes off, and
amazingly, the number of
electrons actually had no
relationship at all to the
frequency of the light.
And this didn't make a lot of
sense to people at the time
because they thought that the
frequency should be related to
the number of electrons that
are coming off, because you
have more frequency coming in,
you'd expect more electrons
that are coming off
-- this wasn't
what people were seeing.
So, what they decided to do
is just study absolutely
everything they could about the
photoelectric effect and
hope, at some point, someone
would piece something together
that could explain what's going
on or shed some light on
this effect.
So, one thing they did, because
it was so easy to
measure kinetic energy of
electrons, is plot the
frequency of the light against
the kinetic energy of the
electron that's coming
off here.
And in your notes and on these
slides here, just for your
reference, I'm just pointing
out what's going to be
predicted from classical
physics.
You're not responsible for
that and we won't really
discuss it, but it just gives
you the contrast of the
surprise that comes up when
people make these
observations.
And the first observation was
that the frequency of the
light had a linear relationship
to the kinetic
energy of the electrons
that are ejected here.
This made no sense at all to
people, and again they saw
this effect where if you were
below that threshold
frequency, you saw
nothing at all.
So, that was frequency
with kinetic energy.
The next thing that they wanted
to look at was the
actual intensity of the light
and see what the relationship
of intensity to kinetic
energy is.
So, what we would expect is that
there is a relationship
between intensity in kinetic
energy, because it was
understood that however intense
the light was, if you
had a more intense light,
it was a higher
energy light beam.
So that should mean that the
energy that's transferred to
the electron should be greater,
but that's not what
you saw at all, and what you
saw is that if you kept the
frequency constant, there was
absolutely no change in the
kinetic energy of the electrons,
no matter how high
up you had the intensity
of the light go.
You could keep increasing the
intensity and nothing was
going to happen.
So, we could also plot the
number of electrons that are
ejected as a relationship to the
intensity, so that was yet
another experiment
they could do.
And this is what they had
expected that there would be
no relationship, but instead
here they saw that there was a
linear relationship not to the
intensity and the kinetic
energy of the electrons, but
to the intensity and the
number of electrons.
So, none of these observations
made sense to any scientists
at the time, and really all of
these observations were made
and somewhat put aside for
several years before someone
that could kind of process
everything that was going on
at once came along, and that
person was Einstein,
conveniently enough -- if anyone
could put it together,
we would hope that he
could, and he did.
And what he did in a way that
made sense when all of us look
at it, is he plotted all of
these different metals on the
same graph and made
some observations.
So, for example, here we're
showing rubidium and potassium
and sodium plotted where we're
plotting the frequency --
that's the frequency of that
light that's coming into the
metal versus the kinetic energy
of the electron that's
ejected from the surface
of the metal.
And what he found here, which is
what you can see and we can
all see pretty clearly, is the
slope of all of these lines is
the same regardless of what
the type of metal is.
So, he fit all these to the
equation of the line, and what
he noticed was the slope was
specifically this number,
6.626 times 10 to the negative
34, joules times seconds.
And he also found that the y
intercept for each one of
these metals was equal to
basically this number here,
which was the slope times the
minimum frequency required of
each specific metal, so that's
of the threshold frequency.
And he actually knew that this
number had popped up before,
and a lot of you are familiar
with this number also, and
this is Planck's constant.
Planck had observed this number
as a fitting constant
years earlier when he looked at
some phenomena, and you can
read about in your book, such
as black body radiation.
And what he found was he needed
this constant to fit
his data to what was observed.
And this is the same thing that
Einstein was observing,
that he needed this fitting
constant, that this constant
was just falling right out of,
for example, this slope and
also the y intercept.
So he decided to go ahead and
define exactly what it is,
this line, in terms of these new
constants, this constant
he's calling h, which is
Planck's constant.
So, on the y axis we have
kinetic energy, so we
can plug that in.
If we talk about what the x
axis is, that's just the
frequency of the light
that's coming in.
We know what m is,
m is equal to h.
And then we can plug in what b
is, the y intercept, because
that's just the negative
of h times
that threshold frequency.
So we have this new equation
here when we're considering
this photoelectric effect,
which is that the kinetic
energy is equal to h nu minus
h nu threshold of the metal.
And what Einstein concluded
and observed is that well,
kinetic energy, of course,
that's an energy term, and h
times nu, well that has to be
energy also, because energy
has to be equal to energy --
there's no other way about it.
And this worked out with units
as well because we're talking
about joules for kinetic energy,
and when we're talking
about h times nu, we're talking
about joules times
second times inverse seconds.
So, the very important
conclusion that Einstein made
here is that energy is equal to
h times nu, or that h times
nu is an actual energy term.
And this kind of went along
with two observations.
The first is that energy
of a photon is
proportional to its frequency.
So this was never recognized
before that if we know the
frequency of a photon or a wave
of light, we can know the
energy of that light.
So, since we know that there's
relationship also between
frequency and wavelength, we can
do the same thing -- if we
know the wavelength, we can know
the energy of the light.
And I use the term photon here,
and that's because he
also concluded that light must
be made up of these energy
packets, and each packet has
that h, that Planck's
constant's worth of energy in
it, so that's why you have to
multiply Planck's constant
times the frequency.
Any frequency can't have an
energy, you have to -- you
don't have a continuum of
frequencies that are of a
certain energy, it's actually
punctuated into these packets
that are called photons.
And, as you know, Einstein made
many, many, many very
important contributions to
science and relativity, but he
called this his one single most
important contribution to
science, the relationship
between energy and frequency
and the idea of photons.
So this means we now have a new
way of thinking about the
photoelectric effect, and that
is the idea that h times nu is
actually an energy.
So, it's the energy of an
incident photon if we're
talking about nu where we're
talking about the energy of
the photon going in, so we can
abbreviate that as e sub i,
energy of the incident photon.
We can talk about also h times
nu nought, which is that
threshold frequency.
So this is a term we're going
to see a lot, especially in
your problem sets, it's called
the work function, and the
work function is the same
thing as the threshold
frequency of a metal, except,
of course, that it's
multiplied by Planck's
constant.
So, it's the minimum energy that
a certain metal requires
in order to pop a photon out of
it -- in order to eject an
electron from the surface
of that metal.
So this is our new kind of
schematic way that we can
think about looking at the
photoelectric effect, so if
this is the total amount of
energy that we put into the
system, where here we have the
energy of a free electron.
We have this much energy going
in, the metal itself requires
this much energy, the
work function, in
order to eject an electron.
So that much energy is
going to be used up
just ejecting it.
And what we have left over is
this amount of energy here,
which is going to be
the kinetic energy
of the ejected electron.
So, therefore, we can rewrite
our equation in two ways.
One is just talking about it in
terms only of energy where
our kinetic energy here is going
to be equal to the total
energy going in -- the energy
initial minus this energy of
the work function here.
We can also talk about it in
terms of if we want to solve,
if we, for example, we want to
find out what that initial
energy was, we can just
rearrange our equation, or we
can look at this here where the
initial energy is equal to
kinetic energy plus
the work function.
So before we go we'll try to
see if we can do a clicker
question for you on this,
and we can, very good.
So, everyone take those clickers
back out and tell me,
if a beam of light with a
certain energy, and we're
going to say four electron volts
strikes a gold surface,
and here we're saying that the
gold surface has a work
function of 5.1 electron volts,
what is the maximum
kinetic energy of the electron
that is ejected?
So why don't you go ahead and
take ten seconds on that.
And if you don't know, that's
okay, just type in an answer
and give it your best shot.
And let's see what we
come up with here.
Alright.
So, it looks like some of you
were tricked, but many of you
were not, so no electrons
will be ejected.
The reason for that is because
this is the minimum amount of
energy -- hold off a sec on
the packing up, so in case
someone doesn't understand --
this is the minimum amount of
energy that's required from the
energy going in in order
to eject an electron.
So if the incident energy is
less than the energy that's
required, absolutely nothing
will happen.
That's the same thing we
were talking about
with threshold frequency.
All right, now you
can pack up and
we'll see you on Wednesday.